[Music]
eddie brock aka venom is without
question one of the most popular marvel
anti-heroes ever following two
financially successful parts from 2018
and 2021 it is now time to make it a
trilogy this was confirmed by sony at
the racing cinemacon along with many
other matters this is not really
surprising after all there have been
several hints of further appearances by
venom in the past for one there's the
mid-credit scene of spider-man no way
home where eddie can be seen together
with his symbiote at the bar in a more
tropical setting although dr strange's
spell sends them both back to the
original universe a small part of the
symbiote remains in peter parker's world
similarly there's a scene at the end of
venom let there be carnage that features
peter parker which is another clue to a
crossover involving the two characters
that said sony had more to announce so
there was news about another
ghostbusters movie as you can see in the
post-credits scene of ghostbusters
afterlife winston visits the old
familiar ghostbusters headquarters in
new york city there he's alerted to the
presence of a ghost by a flashing red
light thus one knew already with the
theatrical release of the film in the
past year that there's still more
adventures waiting for the young squad
there's not enough information about the
now officially announced movie but we
strongly expect that ghostbusters
afterlife 2 will be a direct successor
to the first part as with venom 3 a
release date is not yet in sight
this year cinemacon offered quite a few
surprises at announcement for movie fans
particularly present was movie giant
sony which of course had its own panel
and thus also all sorts of information
for fans of this sony spider-man
universe or ssu for short therefore
instance the name of the third part of
the spider-verse series was revealed
while the original title was previously
across the spider-verse part 2 it is now
officially called beyond the
spider-verse in presumably both
productions we will see the title
character miles morales delving even
deeper into the multiverse in the
upcoming movie than he did in the first
one in order to fight the new villain
miles his girlfriend spider-gwen and the
new spider-man 2099 who was already
shown a post-credits scene will have to
team up the return of other characters
from the first part is also likely but
not yet officially confirmed the first
15 minutes of spider-man across the
spider-verse have already been revealed
and some insiders reported seeing the
footage in secret on the spot according
to them the clip is set to show
spider-gwen spider-man 2099 and a
pregnant jessica drew battling the
villain vulture it seems that the
selected scene had the viewers pretty
excited miles was also seen applying to
columbia university to work on a
multiverse project spider-man across the
spider-verse will be released on june
2nd 2023 while its sequel spider-man
beyond the spider-verse is set to hit
theaters on march 29 2024
further news emerged about a film
centered around the marvel antihero el
mueto the new character is to be played
by the rapper bad bunny this comes as
quite a surprise because hardly anyone
had the planned movie about the wrestler
juan carlos estrada sanchez on their
radar the leading actor himself is
confident saying that he grew up with
wrestling and loves his new role the
protagonist gets his superpowers from a
mysterious mask that is passed down from
generation to generation and contains a
huge power however in order to possess
the strength he must fight the infamous
el dorado this is considered to be an
ancient ritual that requires years of
preparation so far and murado is not
nearly as well known as morbius or
craven this may change in the future
especially because spiderman and el
muerto meet in the course of the story
and despite the former enmity join
forces to take down the all-powerful
eldorado
sadly there is no official release date
for el muetto yet
but we will of course keep you up to
date
the grey man netflix most expensive
movie of all time has been done filming
for quite some time already
now only a few months before the
streaming started the first shots of the
200 million dollar film have been
released in the four snapshots we see
the film's key characters ryan gosling
as court gendry chris evans as lloyd
hanson
patch s carmichael and anna the armas as
danny miranda in terms of content the
movie revolves around court gentry
commonly known as greyman or sierra 6
who is serving time in a federal prison
there he is recruited by the cia and
trained to be hired gun however he soon
realized that he himself is being wanted
by axia agent lloyd hansen the latter is
not less skilled and seeks gentry's life
as the story unfolds six is supported by
another agent dany miranda a race
against time begins which only one side
can win directed by the two russo
brothers who were also in charge of
avengers end game this thriller is based
on a series of books by marc greenie the
screenplay was written by stephen
macpheely and christopher marcus who
likewise contributed to end game we are
looking forward to the new netflix
project the gray man which is scheduled
for release on the streaming service on
july 22 2022
the cinema con confirms what has long
been suspected
the batman will get a sequel at the same
time the return of two important people
has been announced one is lead actor
robert pattinson who will once again
play the dark knight while matt reeves
will also be back as director reeves
himself did not want to or could not say
much about a possible plot yet he simply
expressed his joy about the renewed
involvement according to warner brothers
chairman toby emerick preparations are
already well underway however they did
not want to promise a release date yet
we firmly assume that we will also see
the return of other actors such as zoey
kravitz or colin pharrell but officially
this has not been confirmed yet
warner brothers also showcased other
projects at cinemacon including shazam
fury of the gods a short preview was
screened showing the main character
shazam in paris on a date with wonder
woman
but don't get too excited too soon
regarding an appearance of galaga dot in
this role as shortly after it was
revealed that wonder woman silhouette is
in fact the wizard the latter warns
billy batson about the daughters of
atlas who were after him new details
were also announced about the dc sequel
aquaman and the lost kingdom
it was revealed that new technologies
were used for the shoot which should
make the movie look even better than
before currently director james wan is
in the middle of making the director's
cut there was also talk of many new
intense characters
another featured movie was the flash in
this case warner presented the first
trailer that included the reveal of
michael kayton's batman outfit in the
meantime the superhero seems to have
aged significantly as he's shown with
long grey hair and a beard in addition
viewers are retreated to a younger
version of superman as well as michael
shannon and the role of general zod
walner brothers also had news to report
beyond the dc universe
first there's the confirmation of the
horror flag the nun 2. the sequel to the
nun from 2018 is another spin-off from
the conjuring universe it is currently
in early production and is being
directed by michael chaves having
already worked as a director on the
conjuring the devil made me do it or the
curse of la loronna james is certainly
familiar with the horror genre
the script is by akila koopa who already
served as a writer for malignant but
more details are not available so far
the second big movie that is actually
not related to dc is barbie
the first picture published shows margot
robbie in the title role
the image could not have been more
characteristic
you can see the represented blonde in a
pink car in front of a pink background
the story is set to focus to some extent
on the mattel toy company which is also
the manufacturer of the world famous
barbie dolls in the real world the
announced release of the film by the way
is competing with christopher nolan's
oppenheimer both are scheduled for
release on july 21 2023 which is
particularly spicy as nolan and warner
have been going separate ways since 2021
due to disagreements over the release
pattern of the movie giant
james cameron's then revolutionary film
avatar hit theaters over a decade ago to
this day avatar remains a milestone in
the 3d field even though viewers still
argue whether the movie tells a good
story disney finally released their
first trailer at cinemacon after quite a
few delays in the production process and
it's just many postponements of the
release date the footage which is still
kept from the public also reveals the
official title of the sequel accordingly
the film is called avatar the way of
water as we've already assumed many
times in our news a first look at set
teaser will be available alongside
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness which has its theatrical release
on may 6th and where a screening of the
video footage is planned one week later
it is supposed to be possible to watch
the teaser online as eyewitness reports
indicate the theme of the ocean
unsurprisingly plays a major role the
navira new kinds of creatures and are
able to communicate with whale
furthermore a major conflict is brewing
among navy tribes for instance modern
firearms as well as bows and arrows can
be seen in addition to the teaser
producer john leno also shared a few
words and confirmed once again that the
sequel will focus primarily on sully and
nathiri's family the parts are also
meant to stand on their own as much as
possible but still make for a coherent
story overall director james cameron
also made us want to see more as avatar
of the way of water will feature
revolutionary 3d technology and great
visual effects just like its predecessor
the movie is scheduled to premiere on
december 16th 2022
the whole world is busy watching the
civil case of johnny depp and his
ex-wife amber heard the extensive trial
recently also dealt with the possible
pirates of the caribbean six although
depp reiterated that he would not take
on the role of captain jack sparrow ever
again he did share the plans he
originally had for the sixth part
apparently he wanted a worthy conclusion
to the series and was even asked to
contribute to the screenplay of the
final film however the realizations of
parts 4 and 5 no longer corresponded to
the ideas of those responsible and on
the top of that deb and disney fell out
which is why there was never a chance
for a suitable ending instead for the
past two years there's been talk of a
new spin-off starring margot robbie
nevertheless nothing new has happened
since
after all the awesome spider-man news
today we highly recommend our latest
original forest spider-man across the
spider-verse there you will be able to
find all the other relevant information
about the second part of this
spider-verse series besides that the
trailer for the new disney movie chip
and dale rescue rangers was released on
wednesday so feel free to check this out
as well
[Music]
foreign